anomie le premier à avoir utilisé le
concept d'anomie et jean marie guyot en
1885 l'anomie désigne alors l'absence de
loi fixe dürckheim s'approprie le
concept en 1893 dans de la division du
travail social et lui apporte une
connotation négative l'anomie devient
alors synonyme d'anarchie d'absence de
régulation et de loi
le mot est recyclé par le même dur km en
1897 dans sa célèbre étude le suicide ou
l'anomie devient une des causes de
suicide
lorsque les désirs d'un individu ne sont
plus limités par des normes sociales le
motton dans l'oubli jusqu'à être
ressuscitée en 1938 par robert merton
qu'ils utilisent pour désigner un
décalage entre les buts définis par une
société et les moyens dont les individus
disposent pour atteindre ses buts
très à la mode vers 1960 il sera par la
suite quelque peu délaissé par les
sciences sociales
[Musique]